so from your years of approaching
corporate sponsors what would you tell
someone what's the first step what do
they want to see what should you not say
so corporate sponsorship is a tough one
because if you've never made a film
before you haven't done anything to sort
of prove your potential you can't just
convince corporate sponsor or Brants you
know or a non-profit or somebody like
that to give you a bunch of money there
they're being approached all the time
for all of these different you know
opportunities but with that being said
you got to realize they they're trying
to do many of the things that we're
trying to do with our films which is
reach people they need to they need to
figure out how to create messages and
have stories that really that really
kind of drive at what their brand is and
so I found you know if you have a film
that has you know some some definition
of sort of a story or a brand or kind of
a strong niche you can often find ways
to get some additional cash or
assistance I think that it's important
you know if you're going at it the first
time you don't have a body of work to
find somebody that does to find a way to
build up your team and your your
documentaries so or your film that
you're making so that you can find a way
to say let's get this this this company
involved and they'll take us more
seriously it's pretty easy to attach a
name of a producer or you know or
director or store an actor or somebody
like this business is all about that
unfortunately you need that sort of
expertise on something so it's gotten
easier for me as I went because I've had
multiple films and I can set them down
right in front of them that being said I
also think you've got to have a story
for your own story that you're trying to
tell and that story needs to match with
that company's sort of approach you know
needs to fit in or it needs to surprise
them and excite them and make them go
okay that's that's the way it is it's
changing so fast like when I first went
out it was easy to kind of show like
this online video world was just coming
on and I could kind of give them a sense
of how we'll be able to
you know maybe create some additional
content and maybe you know tie their
brand into some of the you know the DVD
extras but also some of the online
extras you know there were certain ways
that I could give their brand some
presents and and ultimately you know
make them feel like it was a worthwhile
investment and they get that return I'm
finding you know even the partners that
I've worked with now are coming back to
me and going well this is really cool
what you guys are doing and your films
are really getting out there and they're
all over Netflix and all these people
you know but they're still trying to
figure out they're always trying to find
out how to quantify if it is good if
they're making good investments in
marketing out there it's such one of
those ambiguous areas it's always hard
to tell so I think the more data you can
offer when you go out to pitch to brands
or or or nonprofits the better but you
also have to kind of have a plan like
how is this going to really help you
know help an entity that is trying to
serve its people how you can help them
ultimately reach reach their goals with
what you're trying to put out there and
there's a lot of ways I mean when you
when you look around I'd say definitely
have a nice little presentation not very
you don't have to make it very long but
at least a sheet or two that really kind
of looks good spells out you know how
how this film is gonna help the brand
have some reach and it's not just about
like product placement or you know
putting a logo on a website or a logo on
a box I mean there's so many ways now
that the brand's are you know and
nonprofits are trying to sort of work
with through authentic stories to
ultimately better what they're they're
trying to do and their cause so
I've I've personally made it a point to
try to work with brands that I like and
and that kind of relate to to the nature
of my films I like to inspire people to
live fuller lives
so for me I I focused on trying to
trying to look for companies that are
similar and I could tell my own personal
story when I sit down in a in an office
and talk to somebody so so I think
that's important is to kind of just
think about that that approach is you go
out there is fine brands that are like
you to find nonprofits that are like you
that are like your film and and start
from there you know like these they're
people that work for these brands and
represent but represent these brands are
just like us and I think if you can kind
of go and build a relationship they'll
be more interested in supporting your
your your film your idea your story and
that takes time
like people you can just like making a
film you can just go make a film you
can't just go throw a one film out there
you really have to say okay I'm gonna
start to get to know these companies and
you know you know you can't just like
ride them and say hey I've got this film
and I need you know $20,000 $50,000 or
whatever you've got to really you know
try to get an introduction through the
right person if you can't you know if
you can't you can use the LinkedIn and
various other ways to try to find the
right people who work for a company and
marketing or PR and really just trying
to present your case this is I've got
something that's really really
compelling here and I've got the
newfangled way to do it and I'm
connected to these people and here's how
you know how we're gonna do it I
wouldn't go too fast into that sale but
ultimately when you sit down with them
you've got to convince them that you
know you've got you've got something
that's gonna do a lot for them and this
is a great time for that still because I
think that there's so much content out
there and brands are trying to figure
out how to separate themselves a little
bit be be unique and work with the true
creators you know not just the
advertising agencies ultimately though
advert advertised the eight advertising
agencies have a lot of control over this
stuff creative agencies as well so
that's difficult when you start dealing
with big brands they're ultimately going
to go to do they trust and so you might
have to take a differ
approach it's one area that I've just
kind of avoided you know I just I've
just figured I could put a lot of energy
into that and a lot of us do but you
just get you get beat down so I kind of
you know that's so that's one of those
limitations
maybe I'm setting it too much for myself
but I won't go too much after the big
Nikes or the big Coca Cola's there's a
big big brands we usually focus on these
smaller kind of mid tier you know small
small companies or mid-sized companies
that that might might be more apt to
listen to me so let's suppose it's just
a cold call that you're gonna make maybe
you don't have a relationship maybe
you're not gone LinkedIn with them would
you actually pick up the phone and call
them would you send them an email what
would be your approach how long is your
message to them yeah generally when I'm
first approaching a brand or there are
some kind of a partner you know because
there's many other types of companies
nonprofits even individuals sometimes
that that can that can help a film and
give you know give some money to it but
I usually start with email I usually
look online try to get to know them I
might start with a quick email just you
know saying I love to talk with you I've
got a problem and idea film there's
something that I'm working on in
development with and I try not to make
it too lengthy you know two or three
sentences because everybody's jamming
hard are they getting this stuff and
when they get this long spiel and pitch
it's like they don't even want to look
at it they just want to move on to their
next email or their other thing they got
to do it just it just feels like a lot
of work when you see a lot of words on a
page so I try I start short and a lot of
times got to follow up and follow up and
I'll make a phone call you know every
once in a while I do call like a main
main phone number at you know at a
company I was actually thinking about
approaching Smuckers for Walter because
they sponsor the hundred
hundred-year-old birthdays with Willard
Scott on on The Today Show and so I was
like well I was trying to figure out how
to put this together and you know
truthfully I just didn't find the time
yet
do that but you know my approach there
would have been I can call Smuckers and
and see who would be best to talk to in
their PR department or their marketing
department once you give them an idea
they'll often give you an email or you
know patch you through to someone you
can leave them a quick message you know
and then it's just a matter of starting
to have conversations and usually
they'll want to see it a deck or propose
like a proposal you know short proposal
with some bullet points but I wouldn't
spend too much time like you know you
know stressing over that stuff like
definitely I get some some ideas put
together and you know I have some good
Burbage and you know you know kind of
spend some time tweaking and see what
works and doesn't work but over time you
can you'll find that some B's people
will be honest with you and you'll get a
sense of what they want or what they
don't want and and hopefully you get to
the point where you're closing some
money you know I mean there's a you're
always gonna get so many things like
we've already spelled our budget or no
this just doesn't really line up with
our strategy this year you know really
focused on this thing or that thing you
know and I find that those are you know
usually quick ways to get rid of you but
at the same time they're probably true
you know if you hear that go okay well
if they're saying that what can I derive
from that maybe there's maybe there's
some insight or some clue and then of
course you can start to look around for
people that know somebody cuz a lot of
times when you get somebody who knows
someone you're gonna get much further
much faster if you're introduced or if
you're even able just to say hey I was
talking with Nancy who happens to be
your good friend the other day and Nancy
said I should you know talk with you
about this and that she's really excited
about this project I'm working on maybe
maybe you might be too well instantly
there's like there it's so much more
receptive so it's just kind of trying to
find out a little now a little game to
get them to care and to spend some time
and then ultimately once you're in like
they've got to just believe in you you
gotta be real you know you can't you
can't be too fake and try to used to
sniffing out lots of fake proposals that
aren't gonna aren't gonna really go
anywhere so it's a bit of energy
definitely block off some time to to
really go for it and don't get it don't
give up because it will take time
that you're gonna make a lot of calls
and put out a lot of emails before you
start to see any checks written at what
point those should someone move on to
the next sponsor I mean if you've left
numerous messages do you still take that
as a maybe in your mind no I move on I
probably give up too soon too many times
I definitely you know it's one of those
things we're in the process of raising
money right now for a film called coming
clean and we have the initial money in
and that's closed and that's been great
but we have a lot of different sort of
possibilities but they're all just sort
of lingering so it's getting easier now
to at least get people not to just like
to listen to a pitch you know and then
they're sort of like hanging in there
like oh this sounds good we've got a
number of sponsors that are hanging in
the sort of wings waiting they haven't
committed but they're interested and we
were finding that it's easier to get
these sponsors to to listen to our
national pitch and and so I find like
with that though it's like you know I'll
follow up to a certain point but then I
just have to keep going on and I
realized that maybe if they're not
committing anything that they're not
they're not interested but so much of
this is about educating them like when
you're starting to talk to smaller
companies that aren't that don't have
whole departments that deal with these
types of proposals you really have to be
able to get it and that's why you can
get somewhere if you spend the time to
educate them and help them realize that
you know these films are reaching their
audience these film these films are
these projects a lot of times it's not
just a film it's a multimedia experience
transmedia you know different you know
well you know level of content that's
ultimately going to you know hit their
audience in a way that they can't hit
them by just throwing ads all over the
place you know that's what a lot of
these places are trying to do you know
they're really trying to they're also
trying to develop the audience so I
think if you can kind of figure out what
we're doing and match it to you know
where some of the money is at you can
also really make make make make it go
far you know and it's one of those areas
that like I don't spend too much time in
just because if you get I think if you
get too much corporate money or
nonprofit money it does tend to
you put a damper on your creative space
you know I definitely have felt that
pressure from sponsors where I've got
money and you know I do the best that I
can to serve them but ultimately I'm
gonna focus primarily on making sure
that the the main feature comes together
and is solid and I've seen many sponsors
get worried and watch it happen and
they're like okay this is my investment
and where's this or that and in the end
they're happy of course if the film does
well but also in the end they don't
really know a lot of times they're just
moving on to their next priorities and
they don't even care and they're just
it's it's a weird process because that
you know that you would think that
they'd want to put more into helping the
film do well but they're they're done
once they give you some money they move
on and and that's not always a bad thing
either but you kind of hope that you
find sponsors or partners that are also
gonna help push that film out into the
world
that's beautiful when you have that you
know this is sort of this double
advantage of like cash coming in and you
don't have to pay back you pay back in
different ways because usually there's
content or or something that you give up
for it but but then at the end they're
also going to their huge database of
people that potentially are like-minded
and helping spread the film out there
for you
you